there is the age-old saying that
ignorance is bliss
it suggests that if you do not know
something then you will not worry about
it but in terms of dealing with life
this concept is not possible for a human
being to maintain complete ignorance may
in fact be blissful but we as humans
have surpassed the ability to be of the
complete ignorance required for such
bliss through evolution we have come
into higher and complex consciousness we
have come to be inquisitive and
analytical about the life around us we
are the manifestations of nature's
attempt to reflexively comprehend itself
no human is exempt from this and
therefore no human can possess the bliss
associated with ignorance less cognizant
beings like that of an insect or a
reptile can possibly abide by such a
concept but we are no longer on the same
cognitive field as an insect or reptile
so we cannot live like one therefore we
must not buy into the easiness or
superficiality of human idiocy for we
are all of an intelligence that requires
attention and embracement you must work
to achieve your highest intellectual
capacity and resist being pulled down
and diverted away from caring about the
power of your mind the pursuit of higher
awareness and intelligence is the
pursuit of humanity itself and if you
wish to be in touch with your humanity
you must not neglect what makes you
uniquely human your ability to ask why
and work and fight for answers when we
ignore this pursuit and neglect and
attempt to understand our being and the
life around it we endure unawareness and
lose all chances of ever truly
experiencing bliss
[Music]
thank you for watching if you found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
Channel we are constantly coming out
with new videos to help you experience
life with clarity and Wonder